la jornada resume el ingenio chino para
los negocios la creó hace más de una
década la compañía alibaba para endulzar
con descuentos el día los solteros
estigmatizados por una sociedad que
exige el matrimonio y unos años después
había reducido el black friday
estadounidense a un colmado soviético la
tradición sienta dos certezas primero
que será el día de ventas mayores en
todo el mundo con una cifra que supera
el pib de muchos países y que no hay ni
una sola edición sin recordar de este
año sin embargo tiene un perfil más bajo
hay escasísimas referencias en la prensa
nacional y alibaba ni siquiera ha
colocado el contador que permitía seguir
la evolución de las ventas aclarado
alibaba que este año no persigue ningún
récord sino un consumo más razonable y
ha dado descuentos para la compra de
productos ecológicos la razón de este
giro más que probablemente es la campaña
gubernamental contra los gigantes de
comercio electrónico por el monopolio
que les ha costado altísimas multas
tanto alibaba como a su gran rival heidi